con patrullajes intensos la guardia
Nacional de los Estados Unidos ha estado
cerrando las diferentes puertas de el
muro metálico que separa Estados Unidos
de México en este día que se pone fin al
título 42 de manera que los migrantes
han estado corriendo preguntando Cuál es
la puerta que está abierta y
paradójicamente la que hoy está
funcionando o donde hay mayor
concentración de migrantes es la puerta
42 ahorita
si Dios quiere para poder para ver si
nos dan el ingreso Y que es el fin del
título 42 vamos a ver si existe una
posibilidad de una brecha para ingresar
pues para allá a los Estados Unidos que
es lo que queremos nosotros durante todo
este proceso toda ya tengo tres meses
viajando desde que salí de mi país y
acabó y pues ahí yo les conviene que
agarren a toda la gente que se les está
entregando voluntariamente para que así
ellos vean que nosotros queremos entrar
legal no queremos entrar no queremos
entrar por un lado oscuro de la frontera
aquí en Ciudad Juárez nos encontramos en
el punto limítrofe entre México y
Estados Unidos Esta es la frontera
geográfica de el Río Bravo bastante seco
en este momento del año los migrantes
cruzan atravesando estas piedras
ascienden este montículo de arena para
luego por un socavón cruzar el alambrado
de Púas y permanecer allí en el muro
metálico de la puerta 42 por lo menos
hasta 7 días con el fin de entregarse a
las autoridades de los Estados Unidos
porque eso un centro de detención eso es
una una cárcel imagínense seiscientas
personas en un calabozo que las personas
no descansan no te dicen nada personas
que tenían hasta 25 días retenido y no
les dicen nada Así transcurre este día
en el que se le pone fin al título 42
frente a la puerta 42 del muro metálico
con más de 1000 migrantes esperando a
que sean los soldados de la guardia
Nacional de los Estados Unidos quienes
les abran esa puerta para que puedan
cruzar antes de la medianoche y así
tener éxito con sus solicitudes de asilo